grosse difficulté de ce chantier c'est
leur établissement et deux voies ferrées
après neuf ans de travaux cette voie
souterraine sera ouverte au public le 18
février
elle fait partie des infrastructures du
chantier de la voie nouvelle de la route
départementale 121 à sartrouville et
monte son un projet d'envergure qui a
nécessité un investissement de 96,6
millions d'euros ces quatre kilomètres
de voies nouvelles de kilomètres devoir
restructurer
c'est aussi des ouvrages en souterrain
qui passe sous les voies ferrées à
sartrouville
donc c'est vraiment quelque chose de
très costaud
ces différentes routes vont permettre de
décongestionner les centres-villes de
montesson et de sartrouville tout en
améliorant le cadre de vie des riverains
ça va dégager toute la zone commerciale
dans le quartier dit de lasbordes où les
anciennes la circulation passera dans
cette nouvelle voirie all your door
combrée toutes nos petites voirie c'est
une opportunité fabuleuse de réduire la
circulation dans notre ville en
organisant une voix particulière
notamment pour la circulation de transit
qui était abondante est très importante
dans tout le coeur de la ville de
sartrouville la région ile de france a
participé à ce chantier à hauteur de 6
millions d'euros dans le cadre du plan
régional anti bush ont trois kilomètres
de pistes cyclables ont également été
aménagés c'est route ce n'est pas des
aménagements urbains ça n'est pas de la
pollution ça n'est pas du bruit c'est
vraiment de la qualité d'unique pour les
habitants les travaux de cette voie
nouvelle doivent s'achever en 2020 avec
la mise en service d'un dernier tronçon
au sud de l'autoroute a14